a 26 días de que termine el periodo de
transición para que el reino unidos deje
definitivamente la unión europea-
londres y bruselas ha reconocido que
permanece en esas diferencias
significativas para evitar hace varios
meses que se llegue a un acuerdo sobre
cuál será la futura relación entre las
partes que debe empezar a regir a partir
del primero de enero de 2021 han dicho
además que voluntad política para seguir
negociando pero a ciencia cierta no se
sabe quién se verá en esas líneas rojas
marcadas en tres temas especialmente en
los derechos de pesca aunque éstos
representan apenas el 0.5 por ciento del
pib del reino unido se han convertido en
un asunto de soberanía y en la bandera
que motivó en el año 2016 el referendo
del break si está ahí y la importancia
de ésta y además los derechos de pesca
son un tema prácticamente simbólico
fundamental y personal para el primer
ministro quien enfrenta las críticas de
su propio partido del sector
euroescéptico que le exige que honre su
palabra y que el break shit sea en
realidad un hombre